So what exactly is exploratory data analysis. You
can check out the Wikipedia definition in the instructor
notes but simply put it's an approach to
understanding data using visualization and statistical tools. Think of
EDA as your initial interaction with data. For
example, let's say we wanted to look at a
set of cars. This data comes from the
MT cars data set, which comes with RStudio.
Now we couldn't make any sort of conclusions just
by reading through the table. It'd be pretty difficult.
So instead what we want to do is we want to
understand the distribution of the variables for things like miles
per gallon Cylinders and perhaps horse power. We might
create histograms, which we'll see later in Lesson three.
This histogram shows the distribution of weights for all
the cars. Or we might examine correlations between variables like
miles per gallon and horse power. In that case
we'd want to create a scatter plot. We'll examine these
in Lesson four. Our second goal is to assess
and validate assumptions. In which future inferences will be based.
So we might ask questions like which variables are
normally distributed. Or we might be wondering if a variable
is biased toward a particular value. Now this might
not be the case for our cars data set but
certainly in other cases like social behavior or users
interacting on the web you might find that. Third
you might want to understand the data before performing
and intelligent hypothesis. Well EDA can be the source of
an idea for an experiment. It's not a formal
process of hypothesis testing and
predictive modelling. Ultimately, we're developing
intuition of our data set and how it came
into existence. By examining our data we can generate better
hypothesis, determine which variables have the most predictive power.
And select appropriate Statistical tools, to build our predictive models.